[Music]
you flirts ah it's nice to be back I do
enjoy coming over here I don't think
America has a higher percentage of
stupid people than the rest of the world
I just think the problem is that your
stupid people are confident like in the
rest the world idiots have shamed like
they're idiots and then we throw stones
at them and then they leave and they
learn and they come back and they're
badder whereas over here they say you
say something stupid and people are just
like yeah I run for president why
wouldn't you that don't clap that might
be the bet Hilary you don't know where I
stand
top choice for you guys this year yeah
the idiot that is Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton the nascar jacket of
politicians
let it sink in politics are any better
in the UK we have a prime minister
that's trying to get rid of their free
health care I understand that you don't
have free health care here what I don't
understand though is if you're a woman
and you pay top and shelf high quality
health insurance do you get tampons for
free whenever you go to the doctor's no
why
how is that not medical you're bleeding
sounds magical
like I'm not a doctor but if it was and
you came into my office bleeding out of
anywhere I'd give it a go
and by I'm giving a go I mean like
fixing it not like yeah while you're
lubricated none of that no I said none
of that listen to the punchlines before
you write your blog gets worse in the UK
no only our town porn is not free even
if we have free health care condoms free
to go to the doctors tampons no so
condoms just on the off chance that
you're ever gonna get the opportunity to
use them yet women have to pay for
something that's absolutely definitely
going to happen
in fact the only time it's not gonna
happen is if I don't use the condoms
that I just got for free and then we
have much bigger problems on our hands
gets worse in the UK not only tampons
not free they are taxed as luxury items
I'm not kidding luxury luxury have you
ever met a woman on her period that's
not the first word that pops into my
head I've never looked to the Queen and
been like man I bet she's got loads of
tampons
luxuriate like I laughed when I found
out they were luxury items no because
it's funny but just because you can tell
that it was a decision that was made
when there wasn't a woman within a
20-mile vicinity that was a roomful of
middle-aged white man going oh this will
annoy them and if we time it right it'll
annoy them all at once it's the same in
their California tampons and if you know
this taxed as luxury items here luxury
like right I've never seen a woman put a
tampon in but I can't imagine there's
much luxury to it like whenever I
picture a woman putting a tampon in and
a don't I don't do that but if I were to
like I don't think she's going I'm a
princess like that's not that's not the
song I imagine you're saying well maybe
this is now it's a very catchy jingle I
do apologize
oh it's taken to Parliament in the UK to
try and get rid of this luxury tax on
tampons and still in place and because
people believe that they are luxury
items here's the test to find out where
the tampons are a luxury item buy one
for your girlfriend's birthday nothing
else let's see how thrilled she is so
what did you get me well I know we said
we wouldn't spoil each other this year
but I got that promotion at work so I
thought I'd treat you to a luxury item
[Music]
I'm gonna cut your throat I'm gonna cut
your throat and then clean it up with
these
extra absorbent haw-haw will say I've
got a gone girl this will see how their
skills I think ultimately the main
reason why tampons are not free across
the globe for everyone is because men
don't get periods
that's essentially if man got periods
pull different well I cannot speak on
behalf of all men in this room but I
will comfortably speak on behalf of
myself and tell you if I were to get
anything like a period don't think I'd
handle that very gracefully I don't
handle the flu well let alone waking up
one morning just to find my best friend
dying in my arms yeah women like goddamn
champions you wake up you look down
you're morally wounded got shopping to
do and you live your life if manga
opinions we get the week off work fully
paid you have can't go to work you're
dying that's fair there be publicly
funded mountaintop retreats where we'd
go to you go up there with all your
friends because you've all synced you
know idiots just you up in a mine
watching die hard movies drinking beer
high five of your friends has been a
tough one this month it really has it
really has technology would get involved
to get to the point where you'll be
walking through the supermarket with
your partner you'd feel your period you
know stirring or what I don't know I
don't know where the sign is like a
klaxon blares dog start following you I
don't know whatever the signal is you
feel it coming on you turn to your
partner you go I have to leave I'm dying
press about in the helicopter with GPS
track your location fly in swoop your
way to the mountains and every other man
in that supermarket would be like
Godspeed so Jack
we lost a brave man today
[Applause]
great
[Applause]
you